les étudiants sont sur sept sites
différents sur le département bugue
versailles elancourt guyancourt et
viroflay notamment et ils ont été
identifiés par le biais du crous en fait
le seul le savez ce hébergement du crous
qui est en lien avec les étudiants
confiné et les unions et actuellement
les étudiants confiné et du coup parce
mais là ils ont détecté des questions
qui a le plus besoin en fait de notre
aide
entrant de confinement et par la suite
on souhaite pouvoir pérenniser le lien
avec le crous en période de non
confinement et de nos cours au delà
virus pour pousser la scolarité des
étudiants précaires